>> Laura: JOINING US NOW ARE
TWO MEN HAVE BEEN UNFAIRLY
TARGETED BY INVESTIGATORS
TANGLED UP IN THAT MESS.
INFORMAL PRESIDENTIAL SURVIVOR
ROGER STONE, AUTHOR OF A NEW
BOOK "STONES RULES."
AND FILMMAKER DINESH D'SOUZA
NATION: CAN WE SAVE AMERICA
SECOND TIME" COMES OUT AUGUST 2.
IT'S GREAT TO HAVE YOU BOTH ON
TONIGHT.
DINESH, LET'S START WITH YOU,
WHETHER IT'S THE NEW YORK STATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE GOING
AFTER THE CHILD FOUNDATION THAT
GAVE AWAY $19 MILLION WITH NO
OVER HEAD, NO ADMINISTRATOR
COSTS, WHICH A LOT OF WEALTHY
PEOPLE DO.
THEY SET UP THEIR OWN
FOUNDATIONS AND DONATE THE
MONEY.
WHETHER THAT OR WE FIND OUT
ABOUT THE BIAS IN PETER STRZOK
IN THE MERRY BAND OF PROSECUTORS
THE IG REPORT.
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE AWAY?
WHICH OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE BE
THINKING?
>> I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
LIKE ME, ARE ARRIVING AT THE
REALIZATION THAT IN AMERICA
TODAY THERE ARE QUITE A FEW
CRIMINALS WITH BADGES.
GROWING UP AS I DID IN INDIA, WE
HAD A LOT OF CORRUPTION AND WE
KNEW THERE WERE CRIMINALS ON THE
STREET AND THERE WERE CRIMINALS
WITH BADGES.
THE CRIMINALS WITH BADGES ARE
MORE DANGEROUS BECAUSE THEY
THEY CREPT THE LAW.
THEY EXPLOIT THE NEUTRALITY THAT
YOU EXPECT OF THEM.
THEY PERVERT THE DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS, AS PETER STRZOK TRIED
TO DO.
BY ESSENTIALLY RAKING.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
THIS IS UNPRECEDENTED.
THE FBI ATTEMPTING TO COME IN A
SENSE, SHAPE THE OUTCOME OF A
DEMOCRATIC ELECTION.
THESE ARE TERRIBLE THINGS
HAPPENING NOW IN AMERICA.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
REALIZING THAT SOMETHING NEEDS
TO BE DONE ABOUT THEM, AND IT'S
NOT ENOUGH TO KNOW ABOUT THEM.
SOME ACTION NEEDS TO BE TAKEN.
>> Laura: IT'S LIKE YOU'RE
OPERATING IN AN ALTERNATIVE
UNIVERSE IF YOU WATCH ANY OF THE
OTHER NETWORKS TONIGHT.
IT'S NO BIG DEAL.
LET'S MOVE ON TO STORMY DANIELS.
ROGER, I HAVE TO READ PART OF
THIS REPORT.
A LOT OF STUFF NOT BEING COVERED
IT ALL AGAIN BY OTHER MEDIA
OUTLETS.
THIS IS A QUOTE FROM THE REPORT.
NOVEMBER 9, 262, TEXT MESSAGE
FROM AN UNIDENTIFIED FBI
EMPLOYEE.
DAY AFTER THE ELECTION.
"ALL THE PEOPLE WHO WERE
INITIALLY VOTING FOR HER WOULD
NOT AND WERE NOT SWAYED BY THE
DECISION THE FBI PUT OUT."
IN OTHER WORDS, DELETE WEINER
EMAILS.
TRUMP SUPPORTERS WERE ALL POOR
TO MIDDLE-CLASS, UNEDUCATED,
LAZY POS FOR THINK HE WILL
MAGICALLY GRANT THEM JOBS FOR
DOING NOTHING.
THEY PROBABLY DIDN'T WATCH THE
DEBATES, ARTFULLY EDUCATED ON
ITS POLICIES AND ARE STUPIDLY
WRAPPED UP IN HIS UNMERITED
ENTHUSIASM.
HAS ANYTHING EVER ENCAPSULATED,
ROGER, THE ELITE DISDAIN FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> NOW, AND I THINK WHEN WE GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF IT, WERE GONNA
FIND OUT THAT AT THE END OF THE
DAY, THE OBAMA JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, THE OBAMA FBI USE
THE AUTHORITY AND THE CAPABILITY
OF THIS STATE IN A BOGUS DOSSIER
TO CONDUCT SURVEILLANCE ON THE
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE FOR
PRESIDENT AND TO INFILTRATE HIS
CAMPAIGN WITH SPIES.
FBI DIRECTOR WRAY TODAY SAID WE
RESPECT THE CONGRESSIONAL
OVERSIGHT.
AT THE SAME TIME, REFUSING TO
HAND OVER ANY INFORMATION
REGARDING THAT VERY FBI
INFILTRATION OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
>> Laura: DINESH, MAGICALLY
JIM COMEY HAS ALREADY WRITTEN AN
OP-ED FOR "THE NEW YORK TIMES" "
[LAUGHS]
IT'S ALREADY WRITTEN.
PUBLISHED TODAY.
I'M GOING TO SHARE A SMALL PART.
HE SAID "THIS INDEPENDENT
ASSESSMENT WILL BE USEFUL TO
THOUGHTFUL PEOPLE AND AN
IMPORTANT CONTRIBUTION AND
HISTORICAL RECORD.
IT'S DETAILED REPORTS SERVED TO
BOTH PROTECT AND BUILD A
RESERVOIR OF TRUST AND
CREDIBILITY NECESSARY FOR THE
DOJ AND THE FBI TO REMAIN STRONG
AND INDEPENDENT."
WILD.
THE MAN HAS LEARNED ZIPPO.
>> YOU SEE THE COLLUSION BETWEEN
THE DEEP STATE OPERATING BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS AND ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE "THE NEW YORK TIMES" WHICH
TIME THESE COUNTERPOINTS TO
IMMEDIATELY TRY TO DEFUSE THE
IMPACT OF THE IG REPORT.
WHAT I WANT TO KNOW HERE, ROGER
MENTIONED THE NOTION OF GETTING
TO THE BOTTOM OF IT.
THE TREMENDOUS KIND OF GLEE AND
SENSE OF IMMUNITY WITH WHICH
THESE AGENTS AT THE HIGH LEVEL
OF OPERATING SUGGEST TO ME THAT
THEY WOULD NOT DO IT WITHOUT
SOMEONE GIVING THE ORDER.
THERE'S THE QUESTION FROM THE
GODFATHER.
WHO GAVE THE ORDER?
YOU KNOW, LAURA, THE PHRASE, WHO
BENEFITS?
WHO GAVE THE ORDER?
HILLARY BENEFITS BUT
HILLARY CLINTON CLEARLY COULD'VE
GIVEN THE ORDER.
SHE WAS SECRETARY OF STATE AND
THEN SHE WAS OUT OF THE
GOVERNMENT.
OBAMA ON THE OTHER HAND
OBAMA ON THE OTHER HAND VERY
MUCH DID NOT WANT TRUMP TO WIN.
HE KNEW THAT TRUMP WOULD TRY TO
ERASE HIS LEGACY.
VERY EMBARRASSING FOR HIM TO BE
SUCCEEDED BY TRUMP.
I WONDER IF OBAMA IS THE ONE WHO
GAVE THE ORDER.
>> Laura: ROGER, WE HAVE SOME
EMAILS TO THAT EFFECT.
FINAL THOUGHTS.
WE ALREADY FOUND OUT THE
PRESIDENT LIED WHEN HE SAID HE
FOUND OUT ABOUT HILLARY'S
PRIVATE EMAIL SERVERS WHENEVER
VIDEO STOOD.
NOW I FIND OUT HE'S ONE OF
13 PEOPLE SHE COMMUNICATED WITH
ON THE PRIVATE SERVER USING THE
PRIVATE EMAIL ACCOUNT, SO HE
LIED ABOUT THAT.
>> WHEN YOU ADD TO THE BACK OF
PETER STRZOK SAYS IN ONE OF HIS
TEXT MESSAGES THE PRESIDENT
WANTS TO KNOW EVERYTHING, THE
QUESTION IS VERY CLEAR.
WENT TO THE PRESIDENT KNOW AND
WHEN DID HE KNOW IT.
HE ANSWERED THAT QUESTION.
I THINK HE HAS TO ANSWER IT
UNDER OATH TO CONGRESS.
>> Laura: HE IS GOING OUT ON
THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL ALWAYS GOING